politicians have been getting a bad rap
of late and rightfully so when you look
at the lack of leadership in Westminster
though there's one man bucking the trend
the wonderful Speaker of the House John
Burke o president's home state visit to
the UK has been confirmed for June and I
have no doubt that the British people
will take to the streets and let the
president know just how unwelcome he is
in recent years it's become customary
that the leader of our closest ally
address Parliament Ronald Reagan did
Bill Clinton did and this one will hurt
Trump so did Barack Obama mr. boko
previously stated that he was strongly
opposed to granting mr. Trump permission
to address the house and it seems these
words still stand which means it's
unlikely to happen
Berko along with jeremy corbyn and Vince
Cable has also snubbed the Queen's
invitation to attend a state banquet
being held for Trump at Buckingham
Palace in a world where so many
politicians are bang out of order on
this one Berko is well in order well
June it will be no surprise to you that
I don't agree I think that John burka
yes okay technically speaking this is
indeed his right to get involved and
have his view but I think for me he's
overstepping the mark Aneesa but out
he's really starting to annoy me he's
he's to me getting involved in way too
many things where it's not appreciated I
think that when it comes to the state
visit Donald Trump I believe it's about
the office respecting the position in
the office and not necessarily the
person and I accept and acknowledge that
Donald Trump has flaws has things that
people will really struggle with and
dislike about him but he holds an office
in a country that is very very important
to us and will potentially be even more
important to us purse brexit and I think
when you look at previous state visits
that we've had we've had the Chinese
president we've had Mugabe we've had who
else here Putin have had state visits so
think it's very hypocritical to allow
those people state visits and then now
in order to do how about state business
this is number I'm addressing I don't
want the state visit either but hey kind
of very it's way beyond speaker berkos
brief there are two speakers there's
Norman now Lord Fowler who's Speaker of
the House of Lords or Lord speaker and
there's but it is not solely down to
speaker Berko to make this decision and
I find very set of strange set of
priorities because this is the same
speaker who paid tribute to the Emir of
Kuwait when he came to this country
Kuwait has appalling human rights issues
but mr. burqa can allow him and to
welcome him to Parliament mr. Burt
speaker Berko needs to remember the
position he is in you cannot solely just
listen to people you agree with which is
effectively what he's doing it's quite
give me one second cow give me one
second because otherwise there would be
no point during this show if we all
agreed about everything what the hell
would be the point
and as for snubbing the queen that is
holy he did not want to send a message
he was a prisoner please he is invited
as speaker he's not invited as John
Bercow he's invited as Speaker of the
House of Commons by the monarch that is
the position it is disrespectful as the
speaker not to attend as it is for the
leader of the Opposition and others and
this is the man let's not mention some
of the people this is the man who said a
couple of weeks ago that speaking in
Parliament was an honor that had to be
owned so please tell me how did the
Chinese president own the honor of
speaking
how did India's Prime Minister Modi get
to speak in 2015 when his country has an
appalling human rights record just tell
me how and and the an idea that that he
would not want Trump to come to this
country the leader of the free world the
man who can make our transition to
independence easier with a bumper trade
deal he doesn't care about what you
think he doesn't give a rat's what you
think he cares about what he cares about
the relationship between the two
countries this state visit isn't about
Donald Trump or Theresa May it's about
the mutual interests of both countries
and you should care about that more than
you hate Donald oh sorry
anybody by the way mail and I'm going to
disagree really I am but with caveats
okay yes I attended an anti-trump
protested the Muslim ban and clearly I
was and would have been affected by it
by that I need to travel to the United
States not just for work purposes but
family purposes my son was born there
and he did refer to it as a Muslim ban
in his campaign speech which is why I
continue to use that phrase though the
technical term now is you know partial
travel ban in all the seven countries
but Trump use that language so I'll make
him adhere to his own language I've got
serious grievances with the man as you
know president and the policies is
procedure if there are specific issues
were protesting like that or you know
other specific policies like his
withdrawal from the Paris agreement then
those protests themselves
I applaud and encourage what I wouldn't
want to do is mix my individual citizens
right to protest with our state and the
people that have offices in that state
and their responsibilities to Michelle
making Carol's point so the Speaker of
the House Collins
that's an office he's no longer an
individual citizen
these are the caveats of his statement
he's making the statement on behalf of
the office if you look at what Burke
which is what I'm saying you shouldn't
meet all the points that you just write
but the office you see the office
shouldn't take personal positions in a
sense that's my point so for example
week where we were receiving here if
you're the queen if you're the Speaker
of the House if you're the leader of the
opposition we're receiving the President
of the United States as Michelle said
we're not receiving Donald Trump
whereas I as a citizen can treat him as
Donald Trump and his Bernie's these
positions and views but at what point if
we are allies and if your friend is
going down the wrong path you do not
agree why's that
at what point do you just sit back and
say nothing a lot about know is sending
a clear message that you know what mr.
Trump your policies we do not approve
not at the point where your other
friends and allies are doing not only
one level to two greats worse but
manifold levels of worse than him so our
allies Saudi Arabia in Yemen that we're
sending arms to and yet the Saudis came
here on a state visit we never made any
of these gestures nor this posture in
which China has in turn 1 million
almost in their camps organized
governments do business with dictators
every day of the week Trump is not a
murderous dictator LexA but so like like
for people your inkless before I bring
you in Nick can we it's not often that I
quote Owen Jones but in will could we
see what I win Jones had to say on this
matter there's a proud tradition in the
United States I'm thinking of the civil
rights movement the LGBTQ movement the
women's movement the workers rights
movement which fought against the sort
of hatred bigotry and the the the pro
elite values that Donald Trump today so
encapsulate you're very fair-minded
person nothing if not fair minded to
Carol's point this was a man who was
democratically elected by the people of
people of United so it's probably our
closest ally argument what's your
problem with it it's not about my
problem with him it's about my problem
with what he stands on what his pop well
for starters he's his policies are
racist if we look at the Muslim Bank
America talking about what he's what he
stands for in relation to us those are
not things that we agree with in the
country
this is real politic okay if you're
dealing with world otherwise you
probably could only invite it currently
Emmanuel macron to this country that you
would get on with do you see that is the
real politic of the situation I think if
you look at the threat that Donald Trump
poses to our world in terms of the world
order in terms of the democracy of the
United States the lies if you look at
all that's going on with this corrupt
administration your phrasing and NATO
the threat that we are faced the threat
that we are facing if he decides not to
help us with national security anymore
that's a big threat that we will face he
helps us with it map we do business
better than any other country it's it's
real it's realism I do think it isn't
quite important just to add that there
are a lot of people that quite like
from what he stands for so I just think
I know it not amongst the metropolitan
ollie or the London bubble or whatever
you want to call it but I do just need
to add for balance that I know that
there'll be people watching this
screaming at that TV sets going actually
I think is alright so just have that
there